en fait il n'ya pas très longtemps les
immigrés c'était nous quoi c'était
l'europe
c'étaient les italiens les portugais on
est fruit de l'immigration 100% quoi
même si c'est pas quelque chose que pas
quelque chose qu'on a voulu mettre en
est en porte étendard monde
moi je suis algérien moi je suis
argentin tu vois pas ce que non ce sont
toulousains avant tout ce à quoi on
n'est plus tout doux dingues france m
notre mère l'ait à l'issue d'une famille
algérienne a toujours insisté pour nous
faire lire des poèmes pour nous faire
écrire en français elle nous a toujours
fait écouter de la chanson française
donc il ya bien un port comme ça au pays
qui est particulier un père lui c'est un
art chantal immigrés qui arrivé ici en
moi deux en plan destin quoi sans
papiers en france on voit qu'il ya un
côté plus populaire que l'autre quoi et
ça c'est ma recevoir quand tu dis que tu
algérien life on a un peu comme ça et
quand j'ai dit que l'argentin il faut à
maradona argentine à alive football et
on parlait donc on a tous deux un peu tu
vois sans réfléchir on a plus mille côté
argentin en valeur parce qu'on voyait
bien que les gens ça les faisait qu'il
fait plus vouloir de quoi on parle
beaucoup de statistiques de chiffres de
budget et de la wii et machin de
logements bien je trouve qu'on ne parle
pas assez d'eux d'humains quoi ça m'a
fait un bateau c'est bien sur l'année
mais c'est des vrais gens voient qui
viennent c'est pas des espèces de
mannequin ou c'est pas de la 3d c'est
pas de lait des images de synthèse quoi